I believe that you two are morally
better than Muhammad is
[Music]
so now we can have a simple conversation
right now so what's your question bro
well my question said what is you guys
are trying to do here like what's the
point the point of this okay yeah so the
point of this is to
um
yeah I got you the point of this is to
show Muslims the truth we believe that
the group of Muslims that's here that do
the dawah here
um they purposely lie to the the
Christians up here the Muslims up here
feed them false information and so we're
here to give the accurate information
and also hopefully open people's mind to
start thinking more and ultimately come
to Christ the true Christ because the
Christ of the Quran is is a terrible
copy it's a counterfeit and so if you
have a false Christ you have a false
gospel and a gospel that can't save you
a message that can't say so for people
who believe that Muhammad is a prophet
we emphatically deny that but for a
reason not because we hate Muslims not
because we hate the Quran but because
when we read the Quran and we read the
Hadith he is clearly one of the most
obvious false prophets in history next
to Joseph Smith
absolutely without without a doubt
Allah never spoke to Muhammad Allah
and I heard that Muslims are like being
are you Muslim yeah you must be good and
you're a Muslim too right okay so what's
your question how can we know more than
I guess the millions of here's my here's
here's what we think
we don't think we think that the Muslims
don't even know their own religion I
think that a lot of Muslims have this
idea of Islam and matter of fact I think
that the Muslims that that joined Islam
have a better character and have a
better personality than even Mohammed
did a moral character I believe that you
two are morally better than Muhammad is
and I can demonstrate that to you guys
if we have a real conversation no insult
to nothing just a conversation of my
observations and his observations and we
go step by step I think we can prove
that you guys are more moral than
Muhammad so like for example so for
example here's one of the top biggest
ones would you guys sleep with a child
no you would not would you
tell me no okay Muhammad
slept with a nine-year-old girl Aisha
his wife his child right you guys heard
of Aisha they'll tell you the same thing
over there isn't nothing ever Santa is a
lion right so you guys know what and
just so that we you know because we have
viewers here too go can we read the
Hadith to make sure that we're not lying
what do you guys are showing us they're
like exactly because it's it's straight
from the Islamic sources so for example
you got that so they don't want the
pamphlets I'm going to show you from a
Muslim site it's called sooner.com you
guys can look it up in any I can send it
to you
yeah so
yeah so we have the sources here but I
want to give it to you guys straight
from so not on a pamphlet but straight
from the website itself that collects
the Hadith right so this is from
um let's see which one I want to read
so this is uh Suna ibimaja I don't know
if you guys can you guys see it
great sahih the greatest sahih uh right
here you see the gray gray sahi means
authentic most highest authentic right
it says Abdullah said the prophet
married Aisha when she was seven years
old and consummated the marriage with
her when she was nine years old and he
passed away when she was 18. so he had
sex with her he made the marriage
finalized by having sex with her
at nine years old
yeah yeah go ahead if you want to but
that's that's not right there's six here
yeah yeah I got I got multiple of them
in front of these are the six or seven
and the early Muslim Scholars like IBN
people like that they all say that
there's no disagreement among the early
Scholars among the early Muslims about
Aisha's age it's only nowadays that
Muslims try to uh hide that or combat
that which is why we're here because
they won't tell you this but we will
Muslims Muslims they don't tell you this
when you uh were you born in a Muslim
family yeah and and you were too y'all
never heard of his marriage with Aisha I
did you did hear about it did so did you
know she was a child I don't know the
numbers it's confusing everybody says
different numbers I don't know there's
not a single source that ever says that
she's above the age of nine when she hit
when he slept with her not a single
Hadid nothing authentic nothing even
naive nothing weak all it is is
speculation from now and day Scholars
trying to fix this problem because they
know it's a problem well how do you know
how do you believe that what that this
is they're just making this happen to
for today's people because it's in their
it's in all of their sources the most
authentic sources
and so because of this because it's in
their sources we're quoting their
sources and showing it to the Muslims
and they're lying about it
because they're all the Hops they're all
the Hops recitation but the one so like
the red one that he showed the brother
the one that he agreed with
[Music]
yeah yeah
well me personally the one I have at my
house is this one because oh so you have
the words
wow okay so excuse me the the camera
right there it's okay no you can uh if
we can make room oh you're good
when I'm reading because I don't don't
speak Arabic yeah okay I'm still so
first what I'm doing right now is I I
like learned how to read and write this
yeah but I started with like learning to
write it first yep yep and now I I
learned to read it and memorize it right
now I'm almost about to be done with it
but like that's like then then I'm gonna
go go back and restart it again and then
learn it as I go on yeah I feel like so
then I feel like you should not like you
should be able to like first learn it
and then then like have questions about
it because like you're asking like
specific like parts that you're like
okay Define this for me or it's not it's
you but but it's stuff we've studied I'm
like I'm not going in here showing you
some random word that I don't know about
it's it's stuff like you don't have to I
don't have to know Spanish in order to
uh you know
um do a word study on what the word dios
means I know it means god whatever right
and then I could study how that came
about in yada yada so what we're doing
is we do word studies from Islamic
scholars what they say about it what the
Uma say about it what the sahaba said
about it and then we see what they say
and we come with that information it's
not from us so when for example when Al
tabari says that you know one reading
makes more sense than the other reading
that the other reading cannot possibly
fit then that's a clear that's a scholar
saying that there's a textual difference
those are two different qurans there
it's as simple as that there's a textual
variant there and so when we can say oh
well we we prefer this one when you as
soon as you say we choose one over
another you're admitting that there's
two different qurans you're admitting
that there's a difference have you seen
anyone that like comes up to you and
says oh I don't believe this one yes
yeah oh yes
check check out Bible or Quran on his
videos that he he shows them these
qurans what they say
but they never give
this one
this is a fake one yes this is somebody
printed on there and you know Allah
promised that Allah promised that he's
going to protect that okay he's gonna
preserve that words Allah now has it too
many different qurans there's a 30 to 40
different prawns and there is so many I
mean uh where's Allah now he says that
he's going to protect that where is
Allah he's not protecting
what do you mean he's not protecting
because Quran say that this is I bring
it and I'm gonna protect those things
but right now on this on this planet
you're here on your own world that like
but then everything that you do is being
written down so that's what the
difference this is a problem
you say you stand in front of Jesus on
the day of judgment is that song yeah so
that you say Jesus is going to come and
judge on the day of judgment yes well
we're gonna stand in front of the day of
judgment and when we like come and we're
judges and we're showing The Book of all
the goodies and the badges were done
that's like that's just what you get
punished for any Badness that you have
done no nobody I like that I'm gonna
struck you down right now because you
step you step go you can go ahead and
step up the kitab if you want to he's
not going to stop you down right now but
he did it to the Jews what agenda to the
Jews chapter 4 verse 47 and he said that
because they disobeyed him he struck
them down turned them faces into monkeys
and pigs and stuff
so that's how Allah operates it's funny
how you're about to laugh
that promise is not for that you know
Judgment Day the promise he said he's
Gonna Save in this world
the book just go ahead and step step
down on the guitar some people they are
we're not like I said but first of all
what you are selling earlier don't keep
it like that why is that what is it that
you're not supposed to do it no because
like this is my Bible she said we see
the Holy Bible this is the Holy Bible I
keep it that one there's nothing wrong
with it do you think you're nothing
wrong with that when I was being taught
the Quran I was told that's exactly what
you thought yeah I was no no I was told
this is the worst distance
this is like like a physical book that's
the words of a lot that I should respect
it but see what happened in the Bible
does not say that if you drop it or if
you do that it's gonna be punished for
you why are you saying that it will be
do something okay
intentionally if you do that there's
some consequences right no that's not
Allah doesn't exist but Allah does not
existence
across the street right now nothing's
gonna happen to me I agree
why did you do that to my words I don't
think so because your his words are
supposed to be in you not like a
physical book is just a physical a book
right but his words are supposed to be
on your heart so like the Bible the
Bible says that when the Messiah comes
Jesus Christ that God will give us a new
law and it's not going to be like the
Old Law that's written down but he's
going to put his law in our hearts
that's what that's what our God says so
it happened in a book and this can be
destroyed this can be burnt on fire God
doesn't hold that again he holds how you
how you conduct yourself with the law
that's he put in your heart you know
what I'm saying what's that what's the
love what's the LIE the law oh oh it's
the gospel message that that
um he has given you a moment
not yet
by accepting the Messiah accepting Jesus
Christ
he will put it in you and you and as you
walk day in day out you'll see how it's
implemented in your life and it will
wake you the heck up bro it'll wake you
up I promise you so I'll be confused so
the law is is so Jesus said this is what
I command you to do to love as you love
to to love your enemies and your
neighbors as you love yourself do good
unto others and that you love each other
how you love each other they will know
that you're from me and you have to do
my command do everything I commanded you
to do okay so you have to believe that
he's the son the Eternal Divine Son of
God these are the laws these are the
Commandments that God and that the
Messiah has put in us so he's inviting
you okay so so if you become Christian
you have Dollar in your heart absolutely
so why does Christian still tell like
other Christians others there's no
Christians killing other Christians so
if they're doing that they're not
Christian's only Christian by name like
for example you said if they believe in
God like no not not a hypocritical
belief not not a hypocrite yeah not a
hypocritical belief like for example if
you do you believe that uh
um Isis are real Muslims no right but
they claim to be real Muslims they claim
to follow the Quran they quote certain
scriptures they believe with their mouth
right exactly and so what we're saying
that's my response is that people can
claim to be Christian all day but if
their actions show that their faith is
invalid they're not really Christians
they're fake they're hypocrites
that's what Jesus says that those who do
wickedness even though they call me Lord
those are the ones who actually practice
wickedness and lawlessness I never knew
you he was never with me
so that's that's the type of mentality
that Christ gives us as opposed to this
ritualistic you know way of of how Allah
brings it you have to do a certain thing
at a certain time and pray a certain
amount of times and watch a certain way
in order for your prayer to be accepted
or for your Dua to be accepted
it's in your Hadith yeah but that's
actually better than the Christian wife
was the Christian wig no actually
I actually just have like every most
Christians have a lot of different
understanding of God in a lot of
different ways no Christians all believe
in the same one God who is trying you
father son Holy Spirit I see it I've
seen we so look we we there there will
be little things that we that we have
different opinions you probably pray the
same way so who how do I know and
differently that's right and differently
but that's that's the freedom that God
gives us in Christianity he says pray
talk to your father how you will he
knows what you need just talk to him so
what he'll pray what he'll be praying
for we a certain way but we
we gotta understand you have to recite
the Quran When you pray right can you
can you you do you see that you have to
do something for God in order for him to
hear you that's that's Christ God came
to us because we couldn't make it to him
that's the Christian message you're
nothing you do is good enough you cannot
earn God's mercy or forgiveness or by
his ears if you tell if if you do what
he tells you you probably do it and how
well do you do what God tells you how
well do you do the guys tell you huh you
do the actions how well do you do the
actions well do you ever mess up
yourself
exactly so what happens when we mess up
the reason I'm praying is so that you
pray and then you what is it as for
forgiveness from the sins do you know
that you're forgiven no no exactly you
don't know that you're yes let's just
know you do not let me show you
do you go home and say oh of course
according to the Bible I've been for
ever absolutely let me show you I'm a
short but that's your pleasure you can
well I can also go pray tonight 100
times and be like oh what is it oh I'm
forgiving I can go ahead and leave I
don't know if I'm forgiven or not
because no Allah doesn't speak to you
because Allah doesn't promise you
forgiveness Jesus does
Jesus promises us forgiveness I can show
you guys this notice how our God
promises us forgiveness while your God
leaves you in the loop and so basically
on Judgment Day you're like hopefully he
hopefully he got me hopefully I make it
in you know what I'm saying hopefully
I've done enough to where God is Happy
enough to let me into Jenna but this is
what Jesus says well you know when you
do good you know you're not and you
still don't know you still don't know
you might not go but you know you did
the right thing right but what about
your bad thing your bad things see your
good stuff won't out won't outweigh the
bad or vice versa this is what the Bible
says the Bible says that our good works
is filthy rags to God why because he's
holy he's holy and he's just he's
perfect the Bible
he says that our filthy our good works
are as filthy rags to God and God's eyes
our good works he's like so what where's
your heart where's your faith yes the
Bible says that because there's nothing
we can do to earn God's mercy to earn
his forgiveness no you believe that you
have to do these good works in order to
earn in order it depends on God so it's
just the same thing okay so like for
example do you have salvation as a
Muslim right now you believe Muhammad is
a prophet you believe he's a cell of The
Messengers you believe Allah is the only
true God do you have salvation
are you going to heaven
yes
you're right right now if you were to
die today would you go to heaven I don't
know that exactly
that's only up to Allah I do not know
and Allah doesn't Allah Never Promised
You that right Allah Never Promised You
that right everything that I follow is
the thing that everything that Allah
said in the Quran right so let me show
you
so let me show you what Jesus said I'm
gonna show you the difference because
Muhammad said I don't know what will
happen to you or with me that's what
Muhammad said in the Quran all right I
don't know what Allah is going to do
with you okay Abu Bakr he used to cry
before he died because he was afraid
that Allah will send him to hell even
though he believed in Muhammad even
though Muhammad
myself any time you're right exactly it
means that you you don't know you don't
have this problem because there's
nothing you can do listen listen if I've
been doing really good what's really
good I like everything that Islam tells
me if I do that what does that matter
I'm sure I'm sure that I'm actually
doing this it matters not I don't know
tomorrow so that's why I'm worried let
me show you let me show you why you you
shouldn't be worried if you come to
Christ this is what Jesus promises us he
says in John chapter 14 he says let not
your hearts be troubled don't worry
don't worry about it
I wish Abu Bakr would have heard these
words don't worry about it he says
believe in God believe also in me he
says in my father's house are many rooms
in heaven there's many rooms in heaven
right he says if it were not so would I
have told you that I go to prepare the
place for you
so he says and if I go and prepare the
place for you which he did I will come
again and I will now I might not I may I
will take you to myself
so he gives us the promise when we
believe in him truthfully truthfully
truthfully in your heart with your heart
not not just some fake you know with my
mouth I just say oh yeah Jesus I Believe
In You yada yada no in your heart it's a
heart change you turn from your sins you
put your trust in the Messiah that's
what he's saying you believe that he
will bring you and take you to him sure
let's say right now you do you do
believe in whatever uh that right I
believe in it yes if you hate me enough
I hate you yeah if you just let's say
for example uh just like uh if I hate
you I'm a hypocrite yeah
so what does that mean so like if I hate
you if I hate you then I don't have God
because the Bible literally says the
person who does not love his brother
does not have God does not have Christ
you don't that's not true faith you'll
have to compassionate to kill me I have
the ability to but I'm not going to
that's not going to be enough if I've
done something I would never hate you I
can't Christ compels me to love you even
if you were to curse us out well I know
what if I attack you and you kill me
what about that well I mean if you
threaten my life I'm gonna defend myself
you die in the process that's it no I
didn't I'm not I'm not murdering you I
didn't set out like oh I'm gonna kill
this dude you know what I'm saying
that's not murder that's self-defense so
so the belief is if you're just good
enough to get to there you'll get to
happen not here the Bible says you're
not good enough
so Romans chapter 3 it says all men
everybody has fallen short of the glory
of God we all feel sure we all messed up
so do you believe that me personally
right now if I'm not following the Bible
if you're not following Christ you do
not have the kingdom of God you have the
Bible
yes without Christ because because he's
the only one that can get that can
redeem you from the evil works that
you've done the bad Deeds that you've
done is Stained on you regardless of
what Islam is going to tell you it's
stained on you only Christ through his
sacrifice can wash you clean it's only
through him because he's perfect he was
the perfect sacrifice and he lived the
life that we should have lived but we
couldn't because we're not perfect all
right let me ask you a question
I haven't heard this before so if I just
died yesterday and I didn't know this I
would go to hell
yes so you so you you so you said yes
yeah because if you know that if you do
not know the Jesus
you why would you go to hell because
nobody told me so so yeah so this
exactly today yesterday
that's a good question does that seem
fair though absolutely so the the Bible
says that every person
um it's not that you're going to hell
because you don't believe in God you're
going to hell because of your sin as a
human being God has given us General
Revelation what in Islam is called the
the fifthra right the natural
disposition what we already have a moral
code we know what's right and wrong
right and it's up to us to either obey
that natural disposition that God has
given us or to rebel against that
morality we have that choice and so if
you choose to rebel against what God has
given you that moral compass then you
are living in sin and you will be judged
accordingly so when you are introduced
to Christ which God does he gives
everyone a chance I don't think that
there's not a single person that he
doesn't let yesterday
that's why God allows you to live to
hear this so what that's why God allowed
you to live to do this
unless you're not gonna know the god of
Jesus you're never gonna die because the
Bible says that everybody will know my
name okay
foreign
it's everywhere and this is there is
this you guys the first time hearing
this no okay okay so the people the
people like let's say like
people who live in like in the middle of
nowhere who like
as I heard like that live in that
lifestyle yeah I don't have like the
Bible as a book at the house
yeah who never heard of Jesus or Allah
actually or Allah
like what happens yeah yeah so like for
example is what you just said I don't I
believe that God gives everyone a chance
for Revelation everyone at some point in
their life I don't know we're not there
in every moment of their lives so we
don't know what they rejected or denied
we don't know how God dealt with that
person but the Bible says that he has
shown himself to everyone that he gives
a general revelation we look at creation
we look at ourselves we know that
there's one God that exists so then
everyone who's able to oh so you said
one God that exists yeah so there's
Jesus and then there's father and stuff
father son Holy Spirit the one God
[Music]
but the truth is like but the reality is
that's not true that's not the reality I
don't I don't believe that okay because
if you know anybody who's saying that
they don't know ask them just going out
if you ever heard the name of Jesus well
I know kids don't know that kids we
all know yeah kids yeah
kids man it's different we're talking
about all right adults
they're going to heaven they're innocent
Jesus says that that the Kingdom of
Heaven Jesus said let me tell you Jesus
said before they before they know like
the right yeah they will go to heaven
but that's not according to Islam yes
there is okay so hold on so let's do
this let's do this do you believe that
it will be wrong if God were to send a
child to hell
[Music]
but he wouldn't go okay so what if I
would have he literally says this person
like like if if the kid is not at the
age to know between wrong and right it
doesn't it doesn't say that guys so what
I'm gonna show you I'm gonna show you
where
uh Muhammad taught that Allah creates
certain people for heaven and hell and
even if they're a child if Allah created
them for hell they're going to hell
so let me show you guys this okay
this is in another sahih narration I
promise you guys
okay so let's see here let me guys get
you this
this blew my mind when I saw it
so this is sahih Muslim
2662c so this is one of the it's the
literally the second book under sahi
abukar is authentic right
so it says Aisha the mother of the
Believers said that Allah's messenger
was called to lead the funeral prayer of
a child of the ansar
I said so this is Aisha talking right
Allah's messenger there is happiness for
this child who is a bird from the birds
of paradise for it committed no sin nor
has he reached the age when one can
commit sin so Aisha thinks the child is
going straight to heaven he's innocent
right he's too young Muhammad replies he
says
Aisha per Adventure hold on stop he says
it may be otherwise
so she's talking to Muhammad right she's
talking to the messenger of Allah over
here then it says he said Aisha per
Adventure that means stop hold on don't
say that it may be otherwise because God
created for Paradise those who are fit
for it while they were yet in their
father's loans
and created for hell those who are to go
to hell he created them for hell while
they were in their Father's Law and so
before they did anything created them
for help for help that means I created
you with the purpose you're going to
have no chance it doesn't matter what
you do you're going to go to hell I
created you for this and another person
he created them for Paradise they're
going to go to paradise regardless
but how do I know this is sahi Muslim
bro I can give you if you want the real
book I don't have the book on me but
all you gotta do yeah so all you got to
do is look it up bro look look it might
be like
uh it might be like misunderstanding
because no we're like when the child is
in the wound God knows where he's gonna
go yeah but there's so there's a
difference between me knowing something
and then me making you for a particular
purpose right if I know your purpose
that's fine but me forming where you're
gonna go that's different that's me
actively putting my will
I know so that's the point that was a
good point that you just said you've
been taught the opposite which is why
we're here logic
[Music]